und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und christian sievers
guten abend hinein vielleicht sehen wir
die sache an diesem sonntag erstmal von
der positiven seite
es gibt in deutschland 2009 10 noch eine
ganze menge ecken an denen wir ungestört
sein können vom allumfassenden
smartphone erreichbarkeit wahnsinn ich
kann nicht telefonieren ich sitze im zug
die entschuldigung wird jeder sofort
glauben der mal eine von diesen hallo
hallo konversationen mit gemacht hat wie
sie zigtausendfach stattfinden jeden tag
es gibt in deutschland weiße flecken
ohne jeden handy empfangen
geschichten von reisenden die berichten
selbst in senegal soll das handy netz
besser als bei uns sind mittlerweile
mehr als nur party smalltalk zumal in
einer gesellschaft die ohnehin zunehmend
das gefühl hat diese reiche
industrienationen in sachen
infrastruktur häufig auf dem letzten
loch
lückenlose versorgung mit mobilfunk ist
überfällig hat der zuständige minister
erkannt die regierung will geld locker
machen hat das thema heute auf ihrer
klausurtagung gesetzt in meseberg bei
berlin
idyllische gegend etwas abgelegen und
gleich die frage gibt es ne zb team ja
es gibt vollen empfang im
brandenburgischen meseberg die kanzlerin
und ihr kabinett sind also erreichbar
bei der digital klausur längst keine
selbstverständlichkeit die vielen
funklöcher will die regierung jetzt
stopfen graue und weiße flecken die wir
uns zum ersten mal staatlich annehmen
mit förderprogrammen und mit einer
mobilfunk strategie 5000 massen die dazu
führen werden dass wir 99 95 prozent der
haushalte versorgen 1,1 milliarden euro
will der bund zum löcherstopfen locker
machen
eine gesellschaft ist geplant die den
ausbau unterstützt und zur not selbst
funkmasten in auftrag gibt generell
sollen genehmigungsverfahren für solche
funkmasten erleichtert und öffentliche
liegenschaften häufiger als standort
freigegeben werden gut gemeint aber
reicht nicht sagt die opposition
wir sind die rote laterne in europa beim
thema mobilfunk abdeckung wir brauchen
überall flächendeckend zuverlässigen
mobilfunk aber die vorschläge die
bundesregierung jetzt macht sind
gnadenlos unterfinanziert zweiter
schwerpunkt die digitale verwaltung alle
staatlichen leistungen auch online das
ist das ziel
die familienministerin soll jetzt
vorangehen und die behörden rennerei
nach einer geburt digital überflüssig
machen diese vier leistungen elterngeld
kindergeld kinderzuschlag und
geburtsanzeige sollen künftig in einem
digitalen format miteinander verbunden
werden bis morgen noch dauert die
digital klausur in meseberg im
benachbarten ort keller übrigens wäre es
schwierig geworden
dort steckt man nämlich voll im funkloch
ja ich stecke im funkloch das ist ein
typisch deutscher satz ärgerlich wenn es
zwischendurch passiert existenzbedrohend
wenn man im funkloch lebt und dort geld
verdienen muss bernd mosebach jetzt mit
einer reportage aus einer gegend in der
es besonders häufig heißt kein anschluss
unter dieser handynummer die für
krankenstände haben wir heute morgen bei
den mund hören
liebe anmeldungen jan franke auf dem weg
zu einer seiner baustellen fertighäuser
sind sein geschäft er ist chef der
bauleitung und dann ist die leitung tot
willkommen im funkloch
frahm gebaut mehr als 600 häuser im jahr
monteure brauchen anweisungen kunden
brauchen betreuung
wir haben ihm die problematik dass bei
uns dann im haupthaus die kunden anrufen
und sich da beschweren dass der baum hat
einfach aufgelegt hat auch diese
situation hat mir schon gehabt oder an
den kunden beschäftigen müssen und ihm
mitteilen müssen dass nicht am
schlechten telefonnetz im nordosten gibt
es die meisten funklöcher das soll sich
jetzt ändern
in dieser woche hat der landtag
beschlossen die sache selbst in die hand
zu nehmen
eigentlich waren bei der versteigerung
der 5g lizenzen durch den bund die
mobilfunk anbieter verpflichtet worden
die funklöcher zu stopfen
doch auf die mobilfunk strategie der
bundesregierung wenn man hier nicht
warten
aber nehmen zur kenntnis dass unser
wunsch der bund macht es oder sorgt
dafür dass die privaten machen beides
nicht gelingt und wir glauben hier im
lande für die entwicklung der so
bedeutsam ist das was ich selber machen
aber eigentlich sind bewusst der
notnagel der sich jetzt in die lücke
schmeißt die anderen schließen
druck kommt auch vom eigenen
koalitionspartner die cdu hat eine app
geschaltet mit der man funklöcher melden
kann fast 17.000 sind es bisher
das land will nun selbst funkmasten
bauen 230 masten für 58 millionen euro
es gibt keine ausreden berge sind wir
haben so viel funklöcher dass es die
wirtschaft gefährdet ist dass wir der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit verlieren und die
leute auf dem baum sind
das land geht beim mobilfunk seinen
eigenen weg unterstützung durch den bund
wie heute in meseberg angekündigt ist
natürlich willkommen
75 baustellen gleichzeitig betreut chef
bauleiter franke zurzeit ein drittel
seiner arbeit besteht aus telefonieren
gehen nochmal raus vielleicht können wir
uns verbessern so ein kleines land
jetzt müssten netzausbau passieren und
für meinen geschmack ist das schon über
jahre notwendig und dringend notwendig
und es wurde ganz überzeugt verpasst und
so muss jens franke erstmal weiterhin
viel seiner zeit damit verbringen sich
durch funklöcher zu kämpfen
selbst dem bundeswirtschaftsminister ist
es wie er sagt total peinlich im auto
mit kollegen aus anderen ländern
verbunden zu werden weil er jedes mal
aus dem netz fliegt anke domscheit berg
ist digital experte in der linkspartei
sie sitzt im beirat der
bundesnetzagentur sie lebt in
fürstenberg an der havel im äußersten
norden von brandenburg einer gegend die
von funklöchern durchsetzt ist können
sie mich hören guten anforderung
stadtberg erleben sie denn jetzt im
moment bei sich dass es dann doch
aufwärts geht langsam aber immerhin
nein das kann ich nicht sagen die hatten
sogar gerade einen besonders
dramatischen fall ein paar kilometer
südlich von fürstenberg an der havel wo
auf der bundesstraße 96 ein
verkehrsunfall mit einem sehr schwer
verletzten stattgefunden hat und die
ersthelfer fast einen kilometer laufen
mussten um überhaupt den notruf zu
wählen das sind wirklich keine
luxusprobleme es kann auch im existenz
gehen
wir sehen es geht um leben und tod in
einzelfällen zumindest das haben wir
heute die klausur der bundesregierung
erlebt die neue mobilfunk strategie die
sie da klar machen möchte mehr als eine
milliarde für neue funkmasten das heißt
der staat nimmt es jetzt selbst in die
hand wie sehen sie das ist dass jetzt
endlich mal was handfestes oder nur das
eingeständnis dass es der markt nicht
leisten kann und wird zum einen ist es
ja schon mal festzustellen dass erst im
jahre 2009 10 am ende diesen jahres
überhaupt eine strategie vorgelegt
worden ist obwohl wir seit vielen jahren
mit dem problem zu kämpfen haben
wenn jetzt gesagt wird da wird eine
milliarde in die
hand genommen da wurde auch dazu gesagt
dass diese milliarde aus dem
sondervermögen digitale infrastruktur
kommen sollte versteigerungserlöse aus
der versteigerung der 5g lizenzen
aber dieses geld das hat schon nicht
gereicht für digitale bildung und für
den breitbandausbau
dafür war es vorgesehen jetzt soll es
ohne dass das budget mehr wird auch noch
für ein drittes megathema nehme ich das
stopfen der mobilfunktöchter erreichen
und da bin ich schon sehr skeptisch dass
das funktioniert jetzt ist es ja so dass
die bundesnetzagentur durchaus immer
wieder bei der versteigerung dieser
lizenzen eine mindestversorgung
vorschreibt 90 95 98 99 prozent warum
reicht denn das nicht warum funktioniert
das trotzdem nicht zum beispiel weise
vorschreibt dass es 98 prozent der
haushalte sein sollen und nicht der
fläche 98 prozent der haushalte das sind
nur 90 prozent der fläche und wenn man
sich überlegt inzwischen hat man sich
auch sogar auf 99 prozent geeinigt
aber auch das sind fast eine million
menschen und das ist nicht die eine
million die in köln leben sondern sind
eine million menschen die sich auf sehr
sehr viele kleine gemeinden und dörfer
verteilen und damit immer noch große
weiße flecken aus machen und dieses ziel
haushalte stadtfläche ist schon ein
falsches ziel
dann haben wir noch einen anderen fehler
bei der versteigerung der
bundesnetzagentur durch die
bundesnetzagentur gesehen nämlich dass
man festgestellt hat dass unsere
verkehrswege ja sehr oft wie hier die
b96 aber auch autobahnen auch
eisenbahnstrecken sehr oft kein netz
haben weil dort ja auch keine haushalte
an der straße wohnen dass man das jetzt
neu als ziel aufgenommen hat das problem
ist aber die telekom unternehmen dürfen
sich die zielerreichung gegenseitig
anrechnen es reicht also wenn ein
einziges der großen unternehmen eine
bestimmte bahnlinie versorgt für mich
als kundin die vielleicht bei einem
anderen telekom unternehmen einen
vertrag hat ist das dann aber immer noch
ein funkloch und das fehlt mir ein
bisschen dass man an das reale denkt wie
es für die leute vor ort ist
jetzt ist hintergrund für all das
natürlich dass es wahnsinnig teuer
unbestrittener maßen wirklich sehr sehr
teuer
das alles zu leisten diese mobilfunk
netze aufzubauen das sagen die
telekommunikationsunternehmen und das
stimmt auch sind natürlich viele
milliarden die da im spiel sind
können sie verstehen dass telekom riesen
sagen moment mal
gerade das letzte prozent ist halt
einfach zu teuer als dass wir das machen
können also das erklärt nicht warum wir
so schlecht sind als reichstes land in
europa im vergleich selbst zu ländern
wie rumänien
das ist wirklich eine ausrede und wenn
man sich mal anguckt dass allein die
deutsche telekom seit 2014 bis 2018
jedes jahr zwischen 2 milliarden und
dreieinhalb milliarden gewinn gemacht
hat kann so schlecht nicht sein obwohl
wir eine sehr schlechte versorgung haben
da sind also mittel da und diese
einrichtung einer staatlichen
infrastruktur gesellschaft alle für sich
ja durchaus eine mit linken ideen
kompatible idee die hier aber gerade so
aussieht als soll nur da wo sich halt
gar nicht lohnt der staat das alleine
bezahlen und da will man den reibach
machen kann da machen es dann die
unternehmen und diese trennung zwischen
markt und staat halte ich für
unglücklich da hätte man einfach vor ein
paar jahren schon klüger regulieren
müssen und dass staatliche hinstellen
von masken löst ja auch gar nicht das
problem es fehlen ja auch noch viele
details wissen nicht wer legt dann
eigentlich die glasfaser zu dem mast
weil ohne das macht gar keinen sinn ja
bezahlt die wartungskosten gibt es
überhaupt ein ein nutzungsentgelt von
dem telekom-unternehmen die so ein mast
benutzen und benutzen sie ihn überhaupt
es gibt bereits kommunen in brandenburg
die haben so ein mast selbst finanziert
aber kein telekom unternehmen benutzt
ihn und dann ist da immer noch ein
funkloch vor durchweg wir haben jetzt
schon viel darüber geredet was in der
vergangenheit schief gelaufen ist was
auch aktuell ihrer meinung nach noch
nicht stimmt sagen sie uns doch noch wie
die lösung aussieht also wie kommen wir
tatsächlich zu einer netzversorgung die
alle glücklich machen kann also was ich
mir ganz dringend wünschen würde ist
dass man einmal von dem ziel haushalte
zu zielen fläche kommt aber auch dass
wir die grundlagen schaffen für ein
regionales roaming dass man zum beispiel
wenn man schon sagt dass die unternehmen
sich das gegenseitig
rechnen können an bahnstrecken an
autobahnen dass man dann aber auch das
jeweilige netz benutzen kann als kundin
also jedes netz das da gerade da ist
kann ich dann benutzen und so könnte man
es auch für die weißen flecken machen
das nicht in großstädten wo die rendite
hoch ist am ende drei oder vier funkmast
nebeneinander stehen auch für die dörfer
erreicht es nicht sondern dass manfred
pro funkzelle wirklich nur noch einen
mast stehen hat den aber alle anbieter
auch benutzen können
damit würde man mit viel weniger mitteln
viel mehr fläche ausbauen können dazu
brauchen wir aber regionales roaming ins
gesetz geschrieben das ist leider mit
der letzten änderung des
telekommunikationsgesetzes nicht
passiert grundsätzlich brauchen wir aber
eine andere eine viel ehrgeizigere
einstellung die eben nicht nur so verbal
wir sind die gigabit gesellschaft sind
sondern die bena zum beispiel hat uns im
verkehrsausschuss gerade erklärt dass
ein so genannter funktionaler
internetanschluss auf dem die in
deutschland jede bürgerin jeder bürger
ein recht haben dass das mit 56 kilobit
pro sekunde ausreicht das war meine
vorstellung hat das heute-journal von
gestern mit dieser geschwindigkeit
herunter geladen wurde zwei stunden und
40 minuten dauern
das ist kein funktionaler
internetanschluss solange wir solche
vorgaben noch haben und uns messen an
geschwindigkeiten die vor 20 jahren mal
irgendwie aktuell waren so lange wird es
leider nichts werden sagt anke
domscheit-berg digital expertin der
linkspartei eben heute journal
von heute herzlichen dank vor dem
stadtberg fürs gespräch und mehr zur
digital klausur der bundesregierung und
wie sie die funklöcher stopfen will gibt
es bei uns im netz auf heute.de jetzt
weitere wichtige nachrichten von diesem
sonntag hat die grünen haben heute am
letzten tag des parteitags in bielefeld
über klimaschutz und wirtschaft beraten
sie haben das ziel bekräftigt dass
deutschland bis 2035 klimaneutral werden
soll
der co2 preis soll 2020 bei 60 eur je
tonne liegen über weitere
preissteigerungen entscheidet dann eine
kommission im gegenzug soll es zur
entlastung der bürger ein energie geld
von mindestens 100 euro jährlich geben
und weitere beschluss die anhebung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro in hongkong
eskaliert die lage zwischen polizei und
anhängern der protestbewegung immer mehr
die polizei hat nun gedroht wenn nötig
auch scharf zu schießen
am abend verbarrikadierten sich
demonstranten in einer universität mit
molotow-cocktails versuchen sie den
vormarsch der polizisten aufzuhalten der
protest gegen den einfluss chinas in
hongkong dauert schon mehr als fünf
monate in iran sind bei den protesten
gegen die regierung offenbar mindestens
zwei menschen getötet worden
rund 1000 personen wurden laut
medienberichten festgenommen
die schäden durch die proteste sind
enorm viele gebäude und autos wurden in
brand gesteckt und zerstört die wut
richtet sich gegen die entscheidung der
regierung benzin zu rationieren und die
kraftstoffpreise zu erhöhen
trotz der unruhen verteidigte irans
geistliches oberhaupt kamine die
entscheidung in deutschland ist heute am
volkstrauertag an die opfer von krieg
gewaltherrschaft und terror erinnert
worden
im bundestag gab es eine gedenk akt und
bundespräsident steinmeier nahmen
außerdem an einer kranzniederlegung in
der gedenkstätte neue wache in berlin
teil
auf dem jüdischen friedhof in weißensee
gedachte verteidigungsministerin
kramp-karrenbauer der im ersten
weltkrieg getöteten jüdischen soldaten
starkregen und schnee haben in
österreich zu zahlreichen
lawinenabgängen mit stromausfälle und
straßensperrungen geführt
so war auch die brennerautobahn zwischen
italien und österreich zeitweise
gesperrt lange staus waren die folge
weiter westlich in südtirol traf eine
lawine ein dorf der schreck war groß
aber alle bewohner konnten sich
rechtzeitig in sicherheit bringen viel
romantischer geht's nicht als venedig im
november
zumindest ist dass das bild im kopf wenn
man nicht in venedig ist küsse am kanal
während sich der nebel über diese
einzigartige stadt legt dieser november
zeigt ein anderes bild venedig lebt
schon immer mit dem hochwasser aber noch
nie seit beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen
war der wasserpegel zweimal im jahr über
die marke von 1 meter 50 gestiegen
und heute tut er das bereits zum dritten
mal innerhalb einer woche ein meter
fünfzig das heißt alarmsirenen
vollgelaufene wohnhäuser zerstörte
kunstschätze weltberühmte kirchen unter
wasser
es heißt aber auch geldgier korruption
und bürokratische unfähigkeit die dazu
führten dass die stadt dem element dass
sie groß gemacht hat jetzt schutzlos
ausgeliefert ist
denn genau so schwammig wie das
brackwasser der lagune sind bislang die
ideen das gesamtkunstwerk venedig vor
dem untergang zu schützen kamran seit
jahren berichtet franco supino hat einen
souvenirladen im zentrum von venedig
seit jahrzehnten verkauft er hier seine
andenken er hat schon das große
hochwasser von 1966 erlebt die flut
jetzt bedroht seine existenz es gibt
hier nichts was noch gerettet werden
könnte wir werden versuchen die ware mit
wasser abzuwaschen aber wir sind
komplett ruiniert ganz venedig ist
ruiniert es ist ein desaster
ein desaster für die traumhafte
lagunenstadt der markusplatz dort wo
normalerweise tausende touristen stehen
unter wasser
vorwärts geht es nur mit gummistiefeln
manche nehmen es mit humor
am mittag erreichte der pegel ein meter
fünfzig straßen hotels geschäfte sind
überschwemmt die krypta des markus thoms
wurde komplett geflutet jede zweite
kirche ist beschädigt
auch in das weltbekannte opernhaus la
fenice ist wasser eingedrungen
venezianer und touristen verzweifelt
wenn du das so leid für die menschen
hier
der meeresspiegel steigt und venedig
sind immer mehr ab wenn wir für die
großen schiffe immer tiefer baggern dann
ist es normal dass das wasser schneller
in die lagune rhein fließt die lagune
ist eigentlich nur einen meter tief die
für die schifffahrt ausgebaggerten
kanäle aber bis zu 12 meter
so kann das wasser schlecht abfließen
und eigentlich sollten barrieren venedig
vor dem wasser schützen das sogenannte
flut schutzsystemen mose sollte das
wasser an drei lagunen eingängen
abwehren
seit 2003 wird daran gebaut längst
sollte das milliarden projekt fertig
sein doch korruption und skandale
verzögerten den bau viele in venedig
sind sauer
auch franco supino der souvenirladen
händler
das ist doch alles mist alles lügen dass
mose projekt bringt überhaupt nichts
sagt milliarden verschlungen
sie haben alles unter sich aufgeteilt
derzeit stehen rund 70% venedigs unter
wasser der bürgermeister schätzt die
schäden auf eine milliarde euro
dieses wasser hat die stadt zerstört die
venezianer gehen aber neuen die knie
wenn sie beten venedig wird wieder
aufstehen noch aber fließt das wasser
ungebremst und bedroht das
unesco-welterbe venedig und die
hochwasser saison ist noch nicht vorbei
eine woche nach dem jahrestag des
mauerfalls haben heute die tschechen
einen termin zum feiern aber keine
wirkliche lust vor 30 jahren endete die
kommunistische diktatur in der damaligen
tschechoslowakei
an diesem wochenende ist wieder eine
viertelmillion menschen auf der straße
um gegen die aktuelle regierung zu
protestieren der sie korruption
vorwerfen
vor 30 jahren haben die tschechen
gemerkt wie viel macht die idee von
freiheit und demokratie entfalten kann
heute liegt über allem die frage was ist
schiefgelaufen seit der samtenen
revolution damals ein demonstrant sagt
die demokratie bei uns ist krank sie ist
wie ein garten der mit unkraut wuchert
wenn man sich nicht um ihn kümmert
britta hilpert hat einen begleitet der
damals dabei war und heute wieder
ob nun feiern oder demonstrieren
tom kines steht immer am rand und guckt
sei es zu zeiten von václav havel oder
heute beim festival der freiheit typisch
fotograf 30 jahre samtene revolution
feiern sie heute in prag nehme zwar
dabei als sie hier bekam
da haben die leute hier eingekesselt und
brutal verprügelt dass keiner gestorben
ist grenzte an ein wunder
er fotografierte eine friedliche
studenten demo als die staatsmacht
plötzlich zu schlagen ließ das land
empörte sich über diese bilder was mit
einigen tausend begann wuchs in wenigen
tagen auf 800.000 menschen an hier
forderte václav habe den rücktritt der
kommunistischen führung und frauen
gefangen in dieser umbruchzeit wurden ms
havelse fotograf gemeint habe erst habe
die revolution zu einer samtenen gemacht
die atmosphäre war so angespannt aber er
hat mit seiner weisheit und seiner
lebenseinstellung nur eine friedliche
und legitime revolution zu belassen
zu hunderttausenden versammeln sie sich
nun wieder in prag und wieder steht tom
kines am rand
es geht gegen ministerpräsident fabisch
der mit seinem reichtum die presse kauft
und beeinflusst und der beschuldigt wird
sein amt für persönliche vorteile zu
nutzen ist der druck heute wieder so
groß wie damals damals und heute kann
man vergleichen meint sie
wir sind hier damit geschichte sich
nicht wiederholt wir haben viel freiheit
aber wir dürfen ihren preis nicht
vergessen
und dass man regeln einhalten muss und
die freiheit zu bewahren und ganz ost-
und mitteleuropa wurde damals das
kommunistische regime gestürzt
da wurde geschichte geschrieben heute
ist die situation sicher auch nicht
ideal
es ist gut dass die leute sich
mobilisieren der mann gegen den sie sich
mobilisieren gibt sich demütig gegenüber
vergangenem nicht stolz auf seine
parteimitgliedschaft damals sagt er bei
der feierstunde voller respekt für
freiheitskämpfer wir haben aber die
demos heute lassen ich verstehe nicht
warum es heißt sich demokratie sein
gefahr kennen sie ein beispiel ich nicht
wir haben freie wahlen
ob gegen die regierung oder beim fest
für die freiheit die tschechen können
nun angst frei ihre meinung sagen dass
sie das heute können ist das vermächtnis
von václav havel und der samtenen
revolution
und natürlich haben nicht nur die
tschechen heute anlass zum feiern
sondern auch die slowaken das hätte ich
nicht vergessen dürfen so viel zeit muss
sein
jetzt nochmal heinz der uns mitnimmt in
die karibik nach havanna
das hat ein wochenende der
feierlichkeiten hinter sich vor 500
jahren gründeten die spanier die heutige
kubanische hauptstadt das wurde
entsprechend groß gefeiert am kapitol
dem wahrzeichen der stadt ein spektakel
fürs volk ebenso wie für staatschef die
askanen und seine vielen ausländischen
gäste etwas ablenkung von den
alltäglichen versorgungsengpässen
hervorgerufen auch durch die immer noch
bestehende us-sanktionen zum tennis der
grieche stefanos city pass hat die atp
finals in london gewonnen
er setzte sich im endspiel in drei
sätzen gegen den österreicher dominik
team durch in der formel 1 heute großer
preis von brasilien dell hat max
verstappen gewonnen für sebastian vettel
war das rennen nach dieser kollision mit
seinem teamkollegen charlie claire in
der 66 runde vorzeitig zu ende
auch erklärt schied aus die entscheidung
über die podiumsplätze fiel erst in der
schlussphase hinter max verdoppeln wurde
kia grassley zweiter lewis hamilton der
bereits als weltmeister feststeht war
als dritter ins ziel gekommen bekam aber
noch eine 5 sekunden strafe und damit
platz sieben
dritter wurde carlos sainz seit
jahrzehnten mühen sich physiker ab mit
der suche nach der weltformel einer
theorie die erklärt dass die welt exakt
so sein müsse wie sie ist
das ist genauso faszinierend wie schwer
zu begreifen alle materie besteht aus
winzigen schwingenden saiten die
vielzahl der schwingungen erzeugt eine
vielzahl von kräften und teilchen so
lässt sich die grundidee der
stringtheorie vereinfacht beschreiben
eine denkrichtung die in der physik neue
fans gewinnt darunter einen der gar kein
physiker ist sondern einer der
international erfolgreichsten deutschen
künstler anselm kiefer hat in seiner
neuen show aus der stringtheorie kunst
gemacht und er braucht dafür viel raum
diana zimmermann
anselm kiefer ist verblüffend gut
gelaunt jedenfalls wenn man bedenkt dass
er einmal mehr quadratmeter groß
zerstörte landschaften geschaffen hat
und viele aktuelle politische
entwicklungen apokalyptisch nennt
doch der künstler sieht sich in seiner
sicht auf die dinge bestätigt die
tatsache dass jetzt die welt scheinbar
aus den fugen gerät also das überrascht
mich nicht so sehr weil ich habe immer
gesagt ich hab mich ja sehr mit der
deutschen geschichte beschäftigt und ich
habe immer gesagt dieser morast der
dabei oder des nahe der idee ist der ist
nur dann zugedeckt von der dünnen
schicht die hat jetzt eine weile
gehalten nicht so firma das ist weiter
hält aber in gefahr weil es blue port
ist jetzt wieder so hoch an morast
erinnern so einige der typischen bilder
von zentimeter dicker farbe stroh ästen
und allen möglichen dingen die darin
stecken
16 von ihnen monumental wie üblich
hängen nun in der londoner galerie white
cube
bisher hat kiefer sich bei seinen welt
deutungen auf mythologie und geschichte
konzentriert nun wagt er sich an das
größte reize der physik die
stringtheorie sie sagt dass alle materie
ausschwingenden seiten besteht und will
mit dieser einen theorie alles erklären
universum und materie
leider ist die stringtheorie
unbewiesenen im kosmos herrschen andere
gesetze als sind leisten und das ist
natürlich für den wissenschaftler
unhaltbar
er sucht natürlich das aus zugleich dass
er eine eingesetztes überall keine
anwendung findet und und die künstler
suchen auch das letzte bild das beste
bild es überhaupt ist und es wird auch
nie eintreten
kiefer verleiht der idee von den alles
miteinander verbinden seiten seinen
eigenen erzählfaden 30 vitrinen hat er
mit alten daten gefüllt gordische knoten
noch lange nicht aufgelöst von der
weltformel drohen den rahmen zu sprengen
wenn seine kunstwerke kaputt gingen wäre
das auch nicht schlimm sagt der 74
jährige
schließlich ginge alles irgendwann
kaputt und lacht die ausstellung läuft
in london noch bis ende januar und falls
die lust auf einen besuch haben jetzt
gucken wir an diesem sonntag erstmal auf
das was uns erwartet in der kommenden
woche ab morgen also der heute journal
ausblick boris johnson gegen jeremy
corbijn tories gegen labour ganz
großbritannien schaut am kommenden
dienstag auf ihr tv duell
mitte dezember werden die briten ein
neues parlament
torben liebrecht gegner hinter sich
scharen johnson liegt in umfragen vorn
und oft bei einer mehrheit auf einem
brett zum 31 januar
acht jahre hat es gedauert jetzt dass
die hochmoselbrücke fertig ab donnerstag
wird sie für den verkehr freigegeben
bis zu 160 meter hoch spannend sich die
zweithöchste brücke deutschlands über
das moseltal kosten 175 millionen euro
kommt es in leipzig zum aufstand gegen
sie
von donnerstag bis samstag muss sich
eine gerät kramp karrenbauer auf dem cdu
parteitag in leipzig behaupten
zuletzt gab es immer wieder zweifel an
der führungskompetenz der cdu
vorsitzenden und verteidigungsministerin
mit spannung erwartet auch der auftritt
von friedrich merz
und noch ein ausblick auf die neue woche
das wetter morgen fällt im westen regen
oberhalb von 300 bis 500 metern schnee
im osten gibt es regenschauer sonst ist
es trocken aber oft trüb die temperatur
erreicht zwei bis acht grad für
nordosten 8 bis 13 grad
am dienstag kann es örtlich etwas regnen
später gibt es bei zwei bis elf grad
meist ruhiges herbst wird damit
allerdings eher wenig sonne nur an den
küsten weht zeitweise ein starker bis
stürmischer wind
perfektes fernseh wetter wo haben sie
gundel und claus hier für sie da vom
gesamten heute-journal team danke fürs
zuschauern machen sie sich in angenehmen
sonntagabend und starten sie gut in die
neue woche
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]